well welcome back to peterborough center
one of your views about prince harry's
treatment of his father our new king and
the royal family his military service is
beyond dispute 10 years in the british
army two tours of afghanistan he was a
war hero but harry won't be allowed to
wear military uniform a ceremonial
events marking made his grandmother late
queen but science on the other hand will
be at at least one of the events a vigil
the duke will apparently don naval
attire for her final vigil in
westminster hall he of course did serve
in the falklands war but he also
recently paid a woman he claims he never
met
up to 10 million dollars
to make a court case involving alleged
sex abuse go away so the unpopular
prince
can't dress up but the disgraced duke
can
you might be as amused as me as to where
the line is on this i'm joined now by
journalist north of petrano wyatt and
socialite aristocat lady victoria
aristocrat lady victoria hardy welcome
to both of you it might be the poshest
panel i've ever had
uh
um
what do you think lady victoria bose i
don't understand it personally i've got
no truck with harriet
like in brazil most of times however i
don't i don't begrudge him the right to
wear a military uniform after 10 years
serving his country and unlike his uncle
andrew he has not been involved in a
really disgraceful scandal but he he did
desert his country you know he left the
country yes but he he sort of decided he
basically wanted to completely leave
this country and go to america which is
the worst time and why do that when your
grandmother is the queen and she is in
her last years of her life but that's a
different argument to me okay the
argument is about but why is he allowed
well
ten years once of 20 years
um diff i mean one is destroyed and one
has just behaved quite badly i think
actually both of them should be allowed
to wear them because this is such a huge
event and i think everything should be
put aside and they should both be able
to translate what do you think um first
of all nobody's actually got the real
point of this is
whose decision was it and i believe it
was the queen's decision
and this is what i'm hearing uh
technically
harry cannot wear it's actually against
the law for harry to wear military
uniform if it's a law yes
you can look it up yeah it's actually
against the law because he was stripped
of all his military titles and veterans
who are simply veterans cannot wear
military uniform so my father who fought
in the first world war could not have
worn a military uniform it was very
interesting when i tweeted i thought
harry should be allowed to a lot of
veterans actually did reply saying he
shouldn't
well technically he shouldn't that um
andrew was not um
stripped of his military titles he was
sort of forced into retiring from him
but um well that's semantics
that is semantics i just think it sticks
and i honestly think it sticks in the
gully i think of most of the british
people
if andrew's allowed to wear a uniform
why the hell can't look what sticks in
the gun
i do feel a little bit sorry for harry
although
you know it's a different circumstances
you know andrew prince andrew did not
desert his country and go and move to
andy
a very very auntie harry and megan right
and the thing that upsets me most about
this is the ammunition it will give to
the megan brigade and all their mad
twitter supporters
and i think the story at the moment
should be
not about trivial
training elizabeth
oprah winfrey popped up yesterday well
no because let's be finished yeah she
popped up yesterday saying she hopes
that the family that this
death of the queen can now heal the rift
i mean they're all family and i'm like
i thought are you kidding me you're the
one that started the ring she is the
reason you enabled these two to go on
the
match
without challenging any of this
why he was literally dying they did the
interview yeah well they weren't aware
that he was actually dying
99 years old in the hospital
hypocrisy because the um a source on on
the queen the royal family itself is
coming from
the now radical left new york times
which has hired a bunch of lefty
english journalists
nobody in this country is listening to
them nobody but what we don't want at
this time are silly media stories about
riffs within the royal family well the
problem is there are actually wrists in
the royal family
when you see the four of them together
in this footage we're looking at now we
all know that this footage is misleading
there's no reproach
william and harry
hate each other's guts right and let's
be frank why did he tell you that
um i have sources right who knows but at
the moment they certainly do
is there any way back for andrew into
public life after what happened
absolutely not you think there is i
think gradually i don't think it's going
to happen overnight um gradually we'll
be dead before it happens
well he's that's that old he's not that
up i can't why would he be dead
should he should he be allowed no
there's no public advertising especially
how is someone like you who's a
journalist how can a journalist go and
tell someone in the royal family what to
do like what because
we
played
victoria victoria
when a journalist can go oh well he has
to do this
don't talk over each other here's my
point the reason we're allowed to say
what we like about the royal family
actually is because we all pay taxes
here and that pays for them they live
off our money so of course we're allowed
to have an opinion about all of them
that's the whole point that goes with
the territory my issue about andrew is i
think that charles and william have
decided there's no way back for him
certainly for a long time
and that may be just the end of it
because i stopped guessing
i'm trying i i want to tell you a story
uh i mean um
about eight nine months ago the queen
gave andrew lump some money
uh because she understood perfectly yes
he was one of her favorite children but
she understood perfectly there's no
future for him under king charles
none whatsoever charles would never let
him back
um
william would never let him back there's
no return which is why she wanted to
make sure he was financially secure
and what about okay
though i'm sure that's why i just find
it so fascinating how like people at
newspapers seem to know
every little detail and
actually
no i know but it's like you it's like so
much of it it's made up
yeah exactly so much of it is just like
a little fantasy in your interests
okay
how the amount that the junior was
supposedly paid it went from 10 minutes
let's be clear that went to three
minutes let's be clear
andrew payne andrew paid millions of
dollars inarguably to a woman he said
he'd never met yeah to make a civil case
go away in which she was accused of
sexually abusing her and that's why the
british public doesn't want him back he
paid millions of dollars three million
three million there's no a lot of money
to tell somebody
to go away right now in the worst cost
of living crisis this country's ever had
saying three million dollars in a lot of
money no one is home
in the room
anyway okay guys
thank you both very much indeed for
joining me